realiza la suma expresa la respuesta
como una expresión racional simplificada
que indica el dominio muy bien aquí
tenemos una suma de expresiones
racionales o bien una suma de fracciones
de modo que lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar un mínimo común
múltiplo de los denominadores un número
que sea múltiplo de este y de este
denominador pero no tenemos que 6x a la
cuarta es múltiplo de 3x al cuadrado
pues 6 es múltiplo de 3 y x a la cuarta
es múltiplo de x al cuadrado
así que 6x a la cuarta es el primer
número el más chiquito que es múltiplo
tanto de 6x al cuadrado perdón 6x a la
cuarta y de 3x al cuadrado entonces ese
es nuestro denominador común de esta
forma el primer término se va a quedar
como 5 dividido entre 6x a la cuarta 6x
a la cuarta y el segundo término lo
tenemos que poner con denominador igual
a 6x a la cuarta déjame ponerlo igual lo
voy a poner como 7 entre 13 x al
cuadrado
x al cuadrado y ahora como le haríamos
para pasar este 3x al cuadrado a un 6 x
a la cuarta bueno el 3 hay que
multiplicarlo por 2 para que nos dé 6 y
el x cuadrada hay que multiplicarlo por
x cuadrada entonces multiplicamos por 2
x cuadrada ahora no podemos hacer eso
sin compensarlo si solo lo dejamos así
habríamos cambiado la expresión entonces
como solo podemos multiplicar por un 1
también debemos de multiplicar el
numerador por 2 x al cuadrado entonces
aquí le pongo x 2 x al cuadrado y ahora
aquí hay que tener cuidado estamos
haciendo la suposición de que x es
distinto de 0 x es distinto de 0 porque
si no esto de aquí sería 0 y en realidad
x distinto de 0 es algo que podemos
suponer desde el principio porque si x
fuera igual a 0 entonces estas dos
expresiones racionales no estarían
definidas bueno ya hecha esta aclaración
vamos a hacer las cuentas esto sería
igual a 5 dividido entre 6 x a la cuarta
+ 7 por 12 14 nos quedaría 14 x al
cuadrado 14 x al cuadrado dividido entre
3 x al cuadrado por 2 x al cuadrado que
lo hicimos justo para que nos diera 6 x
a la cuarta muy bien como ya tienen
denominador común entonces podemos sumar
las así que esto es igual a 15 x al 14 x
al cuadrado 14 x al cuadrado más 5
dividido entre 6 x a la cuarta y esto es
para x distinto de 0 x distinto de 0
vamos a ver si podemos simplificar a ver
14 es par 6 también es par pero 5 no es
para entonces no podemos simplificar eso
este término tiene equis y éste también
pero este término no tiene x entonces
tampoco podemos simplificar ninguna x de
modo que ésta ya es la expresión
simplificada entonces el resultado de
esta operación es 14 x
14 x al cuadrado más 5 dividido entre 6
x a la cuarta y el dominio es x distinto
de 0